Charlie is a beautiful long-haired  Persian blue cat and he's really special  Charlie's going to get his first line  cut today he's never really had a  haircut he has dreads he's dirty and  disgusting and it's time I think he's  excited about his hair  um no by the list of it I don't think  he's very excited  hardly you baby oh my god you're perfect  he's not even looking at me he's so mad  he's a little rat boy I think it's  really cute I think he's gonna be happy  he's Mellie doesn't see that happy but I  think he just wants to be free and kind  of was traumatized yeah I think this is  a good makeover for Charlie okay I'll  let you go like now it's so small he's a  small thing I thought he's like this big  boy cat yeah I'm so happy with it you  look so cute